We are going to try to
finish with in fair no today.
And they would like to look at the
last 10 tolls,
30 31 32 may be a little bit 33 for sure.
And this a couple of details in 34.
Um,
from one point of view,
um,
I'll be talking about Dantas
tragic mode at the bottom of hell.
This is,
I hope to,
to argue with you that I will
be arguing exactly. This is, uh,
uh,
a tragic representation.
It as soon as I say that you might wonder,
you probably should
wonder, uh, uh, but the,
the difficulty of such an enterprise,
uh,
and the difficulty of the enterprise as
to do first of all with the fact that
this is a comedy,
so that difficult,
it should go away in the sense that,
um,
the tragic is really part,
not an end,
not a final vision,
but part of a larger discourse that Dante,
we'll,
we'll go into,
which is a comical idea.
He really has this idea of a comical,
comical vision of a or ear
of the divinity. Uh, and,
and certainly of the cosmos comical in
the sense that it's really the feast,
the Feast of, uh, of, uh, uh,
in classical times will be the
feast of the Gods. Here is the,
the redemptive happy,
harmonious sense of it or the whole,
that's one of the difficulties.
The other difficulty, uh, about this, uh,
mode of, uh, the tragic, uh, is that the,
the, um, within the
Christian vision that Dante,
uh, that sort of shaped Dante's poem, uh,
it's very difficult to locate
the tragic, uh, there is no,
that you think is, Eh, Eh,
a Christian tragedy though one might say,
and that will say here
just to sort of of, uh, uh,
give you a sense of how a new ads that
you should maybe is that within that
vision, within that Christian Vision, uh,
we are always told that the only thing
we know of God's presence in history is
the crucifixion,
is the story of the dying God,
all of the story of the suffering of
the divinity itself. It is not the,
once again a final vision.
So there is a theological problem that
he has to confront and there is also an
aesthetic problem, a larger
aesthetic problem. Um,
so to really clarify this issue rather
than just telling you all this comes from,
I will,
I will look at this scandals from one
point to view the point of view of Dante's
uh, writing a particular texts,
the texts about language.
So it's really going to
be about language and,
and tragedy in the belief that this
is exactly Dante's insight about what,
what the tragic maybe.
So let me tell you have to go a little
bit outside of the text for a while.
So when I point out details here
that we'll talk about another texts,
you will see what I mean. You
know, this is a sort of a,
a also a little bit of a
recapitulation for you.
You know that Dante
goes into exile in 1302.
By the time he had written only one book
after biographical book that had he,
the data Nuova they, the new life
that I had, he written only that book.
He would still be known as one of
the great poets of the Middle Ages,
but he would not really be
known for more than that.
It's a little bit of a self enclosure
and lyrical poem, a self enclosed.
It's about as you recall,
um,
a kind of a sense of the self is absolute
that love is an absolute itself does
not allow for the intrusion of anything
within its own orbit and its perimeter
and Dante finishes,
finishes or finish. It all,
finishes it off with a vision,
realizing that has to do other
things in order to go on writing.
He just doesn't write much at that point.
He may be writing some songs.
He is involved in political life in the
footsteps of his teacher Brunetto Latini
are and hoping that his life would really
be very different for Brunette Latina.
Ironically it is not because
actually it's even more tragic.
The brunette [inaudible] 13
it is politically involved
in the history of of of
Florence.
He will experience exile but he will
return to Florence enough to even go on
teaching. Dante are here at has
written and [inaudible] Texas,
like Trasar has written
allegories autobiographical
allegories about his life.
Dante,
we're going to end in 1302.
And the first thing that he writes is
a treatise on language, which you know,
which is called as on the Volga tongue.
It's a text that written from
the perspective of exile.
Very much like the divine comedy
because as a repeat Dante,
we'll never go back to Florence.
The reasons why he writes this kind of,
uh, of, of, of, of texts,
it's written in Latin. Uh,
the reasons are very unclear also
because he never finishes it.
I'm going to suggest to you that there
are good reasons why he could never
finish it,
but he wrote two books.
We don't even know how many he conceived
of a writing. What is this text about?
So let me give you a
little bit of, uh, of, of,
of a summary of the text and then
you'll see how it will go on. Um, um,
reappearing in, uh, in, uh,
in Dante's a poem and the,
the, the final cantors of, of
infant. We're in effect. He rewrites.
He writes and gives a whole essence
of the wholeness of the stacks and the
difficulties of,
and he will share with us,
he sends with difficulties why that
tract could never have been finished.
At any rate, it starts, it's called
the devil. Got It. Real quick answers.
It deals with the, uh, the
origin of the Volga tongues.
He starts very much like a
medieval treatises. Start with,
uh, from metaphysical standpoint,
from the very high. Uh,
where does human language do?
Is Language something absolutely human?
And the answer that he
gives is yes and no.
It is human because we are the only one,
the only ones who do speak though he, he,
he makes room for animals
also occasionally speaking
in the human voice, uh,
and being understood by human
beings making sounds that are there.
And he's not talking about parrots,
he's talking about miraculous
biblical scenes. Uh,
but he started saying the angels do not
speak. They don't use the language we do.
They communicate. Lucifer,
for instance, he communicates,
but he communicates with the other angels
or with God intuitively as a kind of,
so there is a reality that escapes
the human, the human language,
the language that we use. There are some
things happening that we do not have.
And then the language is that it's only
human and yet it's not human because
it's actually a gift.
We couldn't really make it on our own.
It's really God's gift.
This is the metaphysical premise.
Who was the first one of
the first people to speak?
It goes on Adam and eve
in the garden of Eden.
That's biblical enough.
I think it's fairly clear what it was.
The first language that they spoke Hebrew,
Hebrew is acknowledged as the primal
language and he will leave and go home so
far as to say that he brought
his never read, extinguished by,
for instance,
either the fall of man,
mankind or are by the building
of the Tower of Babel.
And the whole question of Nimrod, here's
a whole story about who this Nimrod is.
The famous biblical giant
who built a tower of Babel,
uh, and with a, an act
which he even he Dante.
But this is very much like the traditional
Var, the so called patristic writings.
We'll see as the counter to
the descent of the word know,
the redemptive event of the word made
flesh is really the counter to this human
efforts,
uh,
this ascent in pride of Nimrod to try
to bridge the gap between Earth and
heaven. And this an effort to
that fails. So he would go on,
acknowledge him here,
Hebrew, but I must say, uh,
normally he says that it
survives the story of Nimrod.
He says it has never really disappeared.
He takes,
and I'm only qualifying it,
what did we would call a, an a,
an a historical viewpoint.
You know, he does he own,
it was almost as if
Hebrew is accepted from,
does not belong to the flow of history
and the reality of the mutations that
twitch,
all things,
oh sub lunar things are
prone and are vulnerable.
Hebrew is accepted from it. I stress
this fact because I'm going to go metal.
This maybe toward the end of the term
when we're going to read a parodies or 26
where Dante meets Adam and they
are blatantly, he changes his mind.
It is as if something has intervened
in between the writing of that,
that we've got an awkward answer and then
counter with Adam. When Adam says, look,
uh,
the Hebrew language I spoke
completely vanished as soon as I have,
uh, the, the, the fruit of the
forbidden fruit of the tree.
So the Antigo zones or there's no trace
of the original injury this to say in
paradise,
Dante ready to historicize the
question of a human language.
Okay, but not in this tree. This is a
liberal gathered organs. He goes on, um,
uh, describing, uh, uh, ah, the, the,
the, the, the descent of the word.
So it's a theology of language.
And then book one ends and he moves
on to book two and then book to Dan.
He gives a completely different context,
a different direction in the street.
He starts talking not about
the grammar of language,
where we could call the grammar of
language. There is to say the ordering.
How this language was ordered. That's
what I mean by grammar. Of course,
it's a word that explains letters,
correct users of things,
but also the ordering
of a surgery reality.
He talks now about rhetoric and he
becomes almost a theorist of poetry and
style, poetry and style. He
goes on explaining a four.
Nc goes on wondering what are the
three styles of writing poetry and the,
you know, because I have
been mentioning some of them,
you may recall the high style,
the median style,
the middle style and the low star.
This style of comedy,
the style of tragedy and the
style of the allergy, the,
the middle style of giant style.
Uh,
and he even suggests that style should
never really be thought of as a pure
ornamentation as some of us.
Maybe we do what we think about side.
So and so has style.
You know,
we all remember the phrase that the style
is the man, right? The character. Uh, uh,
but sometimes we say,
well,
that guy writes with style building that
is Breo he has a particular gift in uh,
uh, in, in putting, uh, putting
together words and sentences.
But then fissile two implies that style
is really a mode of knowledge in the
measure in which he says that there's
a high style for high reality and the
middle style for the middle reality,
the mixed world, the Ela Jaya world,
and then a low style for the comical.
Well he did.
He says that if you do want to understand
those who are far below the fisherman
for instance,
or a the clowns,
you cannot really give them the,
treat them with the APP,
that the whole room with
which you treat the kings.
So king speak differently with sublime
kind of language. You see what I'm saying?
So there is an idea that style
becomes an instrument of knowledge.
He goes on describing,
uh, um, uh, uh, the,
the, the theory of, um, uh,
of the song, which is the,
the greatest, uh, the greatest
point, a critical form.
And it's the song because he said we were
bringing out the music of the language,
the music,
uh,
Dante's responding is a little historical
detail is responding to a poetic
revolution that had taken place within,
in Sicily at the core to Frederick.
The second those, prior to that time,
the province are poets would be writing,
composing poetry and would, uh, uh,
company their songs with
dilute the famous, uh,
province supports instrument.
The Sicilians had divided those two modes.
It was possible to write poetry,
yeah.
In and of itself without the accompaniment
of music in the persuasion that the r
two poetry was the effort to bring out
the inherent harmony of the language.
It talks to, discusses the
song. He discusses the themes,
what are the great themes and poetry,
and alluded to that with Beltron.
They're born because Dante says a bit on
the bone was the greatest in writing a
war poetry. Uh, the other themes.
So of course our rectitude
rectitude of the wheel, uh,
there is to say a sense of the ethical,
what are the ethical directions that one
should take the direction of rectitude
or really have the same,
the same etymology, the,
and then also love poems.
So this is the way he,
he proceeds, um, r and d
defines poetry by the way.
He ends with a great definition of poetry.
The poetry is that art
that combines, uh, uh,
music, uh, uh, the art of music, uh,
and rhetoric together. And he
ends there. Um, it's unfinished.
I don't, we'll go on writing other
things. So it's for instance,
a philosophical texts. They bad ethics,
which he also will leave and finished.
And then we'll go on writing the
political texts, the Monarchia,
et Cetera when she finishes.
Uh,
so this is the preamble to where
we are going to talk about today.
Uh, and I think that the best
way to begin is to tell you,
since I'll be told me it's mainly
about tragedy and language.
I didn't want to tell you how much
Dante retrieves over the devil.
Got It. Opens. Yeah. For instance,
and I'm not going to be be giving
you a lot of details, but some,
so that you can be persuaded
about about this, uh,
that this is really a deliberate pattern.
This is a deliberate retrospective
view that he takes of his past,
of a failure, of his own,
of a certain way of, uh,
why does one fair,
what is so an accomplishable
about a particular task that,
uh, I'm using the words that Nimrod
uses for his own tower of Babel,
since you know that it was an,
uh,
I realize that it was an unaccomplishable
task and I find myself using those
words for Dantes earlier effort
in writing on the Volcker time,
but some, some, some connections
between that treaties and, uh,
and, and, and this lower the cantos of
lower hair we've had, we've had the web,
by the way,
I haven't,
we haven't talked about that and talk
about this other cancers of the lower we
are in the general radio fraud.
You'd remember that, right? Uh,
we saw violence now than we saw fraud.
But if you're, if you recall, Ken to 11,
where the map of the ethical map
of inferno who had been given,
none distinguishes between the sense
of fraud and the sense of treachery,
treachery subdivision of fraud,
because fraud can be, uh, reiterations,
falsify, or in general, uh, uh, flatters,
et cetera. These are the treasury is a
worse and that that's where we are now.
We're in the Rome of
treasury and treasuries.
The treacherous sinners are those we
engage in a deceptive violation of the
trust others place in us.
This is not necessarily
true for fraudulent people.
There's a project those we will can
perpetrate a fraud or new without even
knowing you or without even
having anything to do with you.
That question of treachery is different
and implies a violation of what Dante
calls the,
the ratio of the bonds of
love because implies friends,
family, country hosts. I
think the, for instance,
but Beth would be home to this type of,
this the tragedy that will belong
to this type of ethical judgment.
I said the Eurasia of the
bonds of love and nature. Uh,
it is as if, as if, uh, the,
the, the treasurer's sinners,
I really,
those who are in betraying the
really betray nature itself,
it is as if, uh, something is being
said about the day or night late,
all possible, uh, ties within a
community within the self and others.
Treachery is, uh, the,
the, the language of, uh,
nothing. Uh, it's a way
of saying that matters,
but no bond. There's no bond that I
can, uh, I could feel an attachment to.
So it's a,
it's literally a severing of cells in
the domain of a pure arbitrariness.
I mean, this, I am above
everything or I'm below everything.
It doesn't matter, but I certainly have
no attachments to anything around me.
So that's where we are. This is so much
to say where we are in the context,
but the connections with the,
they will carry liquids. Yeah.
I think that even the story of Ulysses
can be read in the light of the,
the got it. Okay. And so because
it's a story of a tragic, uh, style,
Dante had been describing the
tragic style and, and uh, uh,
the tragic style. And the failure
of the tragic style, even the Canto,
the successive can't have, we do the
Montefeltro could be because it's, it's,
it's literally the,
the counterpoint,
the rhetorical counterpoint to
Ulysses is a story of it. The comical,
the comical style.
Uh,
certainly Bertrand the Bourne is a
figure who for the first time and now the
second time appears in the devil.
Quincy and Dante has a great
admiration for Burton, the newborns,
a poetic heart. He says the
Italians don't have, uh,
the language of the porch of war,
but the one who has a portrait war
in modernity is Beltron the board.
Clearly Dante has changed his opinion
here. Uh, oh, he may admire Bertrand,
they're born, but the dif, the strife,
the divisiveness that his
poetry fosters now sort of has,
has made a victim, uh, of a, of him,
but the were pound writes a
great poem about Ezra pound,
about puppets on the bone,
but really keeping in mind more the bit
of the bone or the devil a requirements
here. Then, then the best from the
board as far as I can tell of, uh,
of in fairness. And we come
to 10 to 29, uh, which is, uh,
which I looked at that a little bit,
but we'll come to Ken to theory for
instance, and then painters deliberately.
Now on the face of it,
very little.
There is very little here that has to
do with it. They will get eloquence.
But here he's talking about two
experiences that define the tragic bode.
One is look at this.
So in the time being from Ken two 30 in
the time when Juno was enraged because
of similar, uh, the,
the mistress of Jupiter
against the feeble blood,
as she showed once in the game
after mass turned so insane, he's,
he's really talking about the
tragic text that divide, uh,
the child where the gods
themselves within the world,
the classical world that gods themselves
into have been said to be wounded by
exactly the same mad passions that
drive human beings to destruction.
Yeah. This is Juno. Juno doesn't
really die, but she will, she will,
uh, she suffers the same passions. So
there's a language here of the tragic,
and let's call it the
myth of boy, I can, I,
it's a kind of a classical
theology being tied to weather.
And then the story of the
Trojans once again and feet,
no fury of Thebes or Troy was Evan.
So cruel against any et cetera.
And then even further, um, on,
on Canto 30 line 40,
the story of mirror, uh,
the young woman, um, who,
uh, it's, it's, it's,
it's a classical story. So it's
also, it's an obedient story.
The woman who is inflamed by passion,
uh,
incestuous passion, uh, and, and,
and impersonate somebody else in order
to be able to sleep with her are her
father. So there is, this is
a part of all, uh, uh, or,
or over all this, this, uh, uh,
tragic comic, call it
tragic perimeter, but it,
everything focuses on
this story of sign on.
I think I like this idea of sign on
who is an impersonator in the falsify.
You know,
you don't really have to know a lot of
Italian to know the dentist is really
planning on the name. See
none, which means yes and no,
uh,
the very representation of the
falsifications suffocation of personality,
but it's so the tragic is tied
to some sense of identity, uh,
people who do not know exactly,
and that's impersonation a human beings
who may not know who they are and who
may take on some kind of either figuration
or the reality of somebody else.
So it's, it's this idea of, uh, of, of,
of an ambiguity already betrayed by,
by the name.
So the connection between madness and
tragic. And let me move on to Canto,
uh, 31, um,
where Dante enters and
now meets the giants,
uh, clearly figuration and them an echo
of the devil. Guardiola Quincy. This,
uh, uh, and one of them is Nimrod.
So this is really a deliberate reflection.
Let me just read a little bit of, uh,
this, uh, uh,
online sixth and following
where he Dante here, uh,
some kind of sounds and
every commentator of yours,
mine certainly does, will
tell you that, uh, uh,
Dante's using just a, some gibberish,
nobody knows what it means.
These are the words or fair.
My Amex Zombie army began the savage
mouth to cry for which no sweeter psalms,
where am I leader towards him?
It's stupid soul.
Keep today Horn and vent myself with them.
And with that,
uh,
when rage or other passion takes the
search at Dinette bewilders hole and Asha
find the strap that holds it tight,
see how it lies across the great,
they're great chest. Then he said
to me, he is his own accuser.
This is Nimrod through who's
wicked device. The world is not,
or one soul speech.
Let us leave him there
and not talk in vain.
For every language is to
him is his two others,
which is known to none.
We made our way,
therefore farther on turning
left and found the next,
they're both sharp of savagery and larger,
et cetera.
He meets a number of other giants.
Um,
why does Dante,
first of all mentioned giants?
Both of the devil got quilts in here.
What is really what is really the point
of level Gordillo Quinn's. Yeah. Uh,
there is a way in which the little
better it liquids is written from the
viewpoint of Nimrod's because what Dante
wants to do something exactly like what
Nimrod attempted neighborhood wanted
to combine all the possible languages.
That's what Baybou the confusion
of the tongues comes about,
was to combine,
uh,
to build the tower whereby
human beings can reach heaven.
And I said that it's really the
other side of the incarnational word,
the word that joins a heaven and
earth one is one of the scent.
The other one is the pride
of a sense that Nimrod once,
this is the giant ish.
This is,
it's his is a sin of
sin. It's, it's a trait.
It's a trait of his,
of knowing things.
He wants to occupy a kind
of superior perspective.
That's what is being a giant means,
a superior perspective from which he
can really see the whole of the world
around him and then be able to
transcend the world of contingency.
This is the problem
with, with, with Nimrod,
this is what the Tower of Babel is about.
And the theological answer is
that you don't do this by pride.
You really ought to do it by, uh,
humility. Not but time to go up,
but it buy, Eh, going down.
What I'm really also saying,
and we could talk about this, there's a
connection between pride and perspective.
Uh,
so they even get an acquaintance.
He's also a text of perspective is,
do you know what I mean by perspective?
Is What do we have Red Sofa perspective,
we simply means the presence of
viewpoints, various viewpoints,
which ones I'm help managers spoke
control. I know all viewpoints in Tampa.
This is the case. They were the, the,
the whole, when Ferran was written,
the perspective on styles.
Dante uses all possible styles that have
been exemplifying for you here as we
discuss the poem he wrote where he uses
the core three language and the cultural
rhetoric. Oh, Francesca, the,
the other court, the court,
the legal court of peer peer
delivering are the core to the,
let's say the schools
with Brunetto Latini. Uh,
the language of the profits are,
he uses old perspectives. It's,
it's the whole, the whole of the
divine comedy is such a perspective, a,
a perspective. His story.
Some of you might say, well,
you really are using a language that
doesn't belong to Dante's own culture.
There will be a very legitimate
objections because when we talk about
perspective,
we usually think about this is really
that evolutionary language of 15th century
art. You May, some of you
may be art historians, you
know, you may know that, um,
though I could respond to you that
actually there was a certain knowledge of
perspective of prospective
earlier than Dante. Nonetheless,
even if they did not have
a theory of perspective,
which I'll explain in a moment, they
had the practice of perspective in art,
we usually speak of perspective in art
and we usually link it with, for instance,
a figure such as a Alberti.
You know,
you know who he is,
this 15th century theorist of art who
wrote a treatise called on painting,
right?
1436 where he Altium literally theorizes
that which other painters from job talk
Dantes friend Dantes,
they were together in,
in Padua for years. We're done. That
was in exile and, and, and, and,
and Giotto was painting in the
Scrovegni Chapel right there.
So you could imagine they would
be meeting, they knew each other,
they were contemporaries. One is
a year younger than the other. Uh,
Dante is a year older and
George . Uh, so they,
there was a practice or perspective
what is perspective for, for,
for uh,
Alberti.
It simply means the discovery that the
mode of representation practiced in the
Middle Ages really lacked depth,
not only that,
like depth and that somehow they believe
that the world of appearance and the
world of reality coincide.
It perspective means that the world that
I see shifts changes according to the
position that I, the spectator
occupy in the field of vision.
I'm here and they're going to
show you that I see things,
I use it in their cannot see and vice
versa. You see things that I cannot see.
So the perception of reality changes
according to the position we occupy.
That's perspective.
Not only that,
it also implies the possibility
of manipulation of the
space that we witnessed.
We see this particular space. We can
change it according to our, uh, uh,
this according to the
blows of, uh, of, of um,
uh, the eyes, the position of the
eye according to the hour of the day.
I see things which are always different.
So this is perspective and therefore
the language of renaissance, uh,
there's a called Quattrocento
the 15th century changes,
the whole medieval idea of representation
where things were represented,
the way they appeared and
they say that's not true.
We are never going to give the
sense of the reality of things,
but the appearance of things. So that's,
that's really the great the difference.
Dante uses this perspectivism,
which I repeat really means a way of
assembling various points of view in the
persuasion that this
is what really he has.
He's in exile and 13,
oh two,
he has been traveling all over Italy and
he thinks that he can go on forging the
language, the vernacular language
of Italy. He will go on. I mean,
just to go back to say other things
about the devil guided acquaints.
I didn't say he would go on
writing about the proximity of the,
the romance languages.
He invents this idea of romance languages.
He says that the way in
which French province,
our Spanish Italian
are connected together.
He says it's one particle
the way we use the sea. Uh,
or will he talks about the province are
the, you know, the uh, his uh, his uh, uh,
they actually caused the
say yes. They say arc. Uh,
which I guess is when the other, when
I had to make an affirmative statement.
So he goes on talking about the,
see the language of the c, the way,
the language of the,
no,
this is what the families of
languages are being built together.
So Nimrod to go back to the text,
the story of Nimrod and the story of
Dante seems to be strangely that it costs,
what is more, look at what
he does. He, she is so the,
the link with the devil kind of
requests are just extraordinary.
Even this line that everybody thinks
it doesn't mean anything. Rafael,
my yard Mech, Zombie army.
If you look at it carefully,
really going to tell you something,
it is an imperfect,
there's one letter anagram or the Hebrew
line from the psalms in the reference
to suite of psalms.
Next will tell you that this
Dante's really giving me the source,
the lion and the psalm.
Psalm 22 is Ellie,
Ellie Lama Sabachthani.
The fact that there is
no exact respondents only
means that the editors have
missed the point that they
should amend the text.
So it would be an argument for
textual emendation would like,
that's something that the philologists
are very careful about doing,
but they always welcome possibilities.
This is really, it's an amazing,
so he's choosing Hebrew there because
that's what he had said in the devil.
Got It. Laquinta Hebrew
though this is an inverter,
twisted language by the
builder of the Tower of Babel,
we are not supposed to understand
it and yet behind all confusion,
there is still something intelligible.
That's the argument behind all
twisted appearances of things. There,
there is a residue of intellect,
of intelligent,
intelligible,
uh,
unintelligible message that
is going to be given, uh, the,
the what is, what are these
words by the way, Ellie, Ellie,
lamaze or back then it
was, I, I, I can go in,
right pass it very quickly in the
belief that everybody will know.
These are the words, psalm 22, the,
they're the words that
Jesus on the cross sites,
father, father, why have you forsaken me?
It's really big tragic moment or the
moment of the crucifixion where the sun
feels or is completely abandoned and
that somehow the whole divine pray,
the whole divine, uh, older is
no longer responsive to him.
It's really the moment of the
theological despair that we call it.
Okay. And pantry. So that's now, uh,
and that he is aware that if Nimrod,
that's what he's done,
I think is telling member of obliquely,
had he not been so stupid,
he would have known by
using this kind of language,
the way in which it would have been
reaching heaven. You know, the, the,
the way to have it is the
way to go down into humility.
And up through the building of the Tower
of Babel and the confusion of tongues.
And then there is this whole argument
here, which I'm not going to go into work,
but the, the confusion, the
perceptual confusion perspective,
[inaudible] is a far away and he mistakes
the giants for towers reference to
this famous town. There's
still, if you go on the, on
the, on, on, on, on the highway,
uh, you can still see
Montera Joan. And that's,
that's what Dante we're went by and he
thinks that the giants have towers a
question of perspective because in
perspective, you learn that you see,
according to the distance of the,
the arrive from the object.
This is the basic mathematics,
the geometry,
that rouge and sustains the,
the theory of, uh, perspective.
Uh, and then, uh, uh,
it will continue, um,
with,
um,
and let me just go on to
a further case of, uh,
this, uh, this question of, uh,
of frustrated and I want to read
through in with some care 33, uh,
returned to Ken to 32 with more pursuing
this line of references to the devil
gather loquia answer. Look
at his head. I the heart.
It's the beginning of the text.
Would you like to read?
We read in from Canto 32 line one 12th
Oh, I'm impressed. I didn't
mean that. Uh, go ahead.
Kent from Canto 32 line one
to 12 in English one 12th
how do I the harsh grading rhymes that
would be fitting for the small hole on
like all the other rocks bear down.
I would impress out more completely the
staff with Mike but since I have not,
since I have not, it is not without
fear. I bring myself to speak,
which we describe the bottom of all the
universe is no enterprise to undertake
in sport or for a tongue that pride mama
or that and Babbo but may those ladies
aid my first who aided amnion to wall
and themes so that the telling may not be
diverse from the fast opiod and all
others misbegotten crowd who are in the
place.
It is hard to speak up better.
Had you here been sheep or goats.
Thank you. Thank you. Okay here.
This is a beginning that in many ways
rehashes what last time I called the
ineffability, Topo should remember
at the beginning of Canto 28,
Dante there is talking about the sublime.
I Tova of Parotic,
uh,
I a vote of a inverted form of the
sublime a saw the horror of what he was
witnessing is such that he could not,
he could not know that he could
find the metaphors for it.
This is now the deployment
of a variant of that conceit.
And they can sit here. Is that
Dante's looking for a style? Yes.
Perspective. There must be a unique
style for this particular reality.
And he start, I cannot go on
using the language of familiarity.
I have to use the bat boy,
Mama the language of a child
because this is just there,
the treasurer souls who have betrayed
first of all family. So there is,
that is a sort of a tragic resonance
even at on that little motif.
This cannot be done in the
ordinary familiar language
of every day because this
sinners have indeed betrayed
all of that. No. Uh,
I can probably be done at all because
I'm aware and how he could he not be in
this area of treachery and fraud,
that words and deeds do not
necessarily belong together.
I'm only paraphrasing the techs.
So, uh, a search for style,
which he understands as a form of
what is convenient, what is decorous,
where it's appropriate.
That's the metaphor he uses.
It's better if it were an argument of
little guard Eloquii answer the principle
of convention and convenient area in Latin
and the convenience with a particular
language over when one is dealing
with a particular reality. And,
and, and, and the further problem of
what kind of style do I had is there,
is it, can I get, in order to
represent this kind of world,
he appeals to anthem and the
building of themes, once again,
this is a tragic story of
themes and the Blakely,
he's also appealing to something that
he himself has written since [inaudible]
is the poor to move stones,
but the power of his language
I aversion of, of, of Orpheus.
Who plicate tames the,
the savage beasts within the
heart within us. Uh, he's,
he's wants to be a kind of Ambien. The
fact is that he has written stony rhymes.
He has written, he's moving. It's a,
it's a sort of retrospective view
that he takes. He's, he's, he's,
he thinks that the only kind of a style
adequate to this reality is the style of
the crazy poems.
They're presenting that crazy time of his
life for this lady of stone who change
would change him into stone.
We an allusion to this appeared in the
Canto of the Medusa in Canto nine of in
fairness. So that that's
really, it begins with this,
the search for a particular style and uh,
uh, Dante, we'll go on, uh, uh,
through this, uh, uh, this,
this kind of, this, this whole,
whole world of further into the frozen
ice in us of health is not fire burning
fire. Uh, and now that's
how the Canto and,
and we start with the next candle.
We had already left
him a land line one 22,
when I saw two frozen too frozen in one
hole so that the one head was a hood to
the other.
And as bread is devoured for hunger.
So, you know, we're approaching the most,
to me, the most unbearable
scene of, of, of inferno,
that Canada cannibalization,
human being cannibalizing,
literally eating the other.
I know that some of you may have
your sense of your taste is,
can be different.
To me,
this is really the worst
possible representation.
Tragic representation here. The one
above satisfies teeth in the other,
at the place where the Brain
Jones, the nape, tedious node,
the temples of [inaudible] posts for rage,
justice he was doing with a score.
And the other parts,
oh,
thou who buys will be still a token
shows the hatred against him that he just
tell me that.
Cause I said on this agreement,
if thou his reason in dye
complaint against him,
I knowing who you are
and what his sin shall,
yet the required the in the,
um,
in the world evolve.
If this tongue I talk with being naught,
whether it,
so we're approaching a moment where
literally silence envelops or possible or
presentations,
there's something that nothing,
not old can be all too at the sayable
say something that escapes the Sayable,
Eh,
it's,
it's that boundary and that
boundary that Dante places us.
So, uh, this is, uh, you know where
it is. I have to read this, uh,
this exchange. I will read it in
and then we try to comment on it.
I wish you could have a
discussion about this.
This canto that sinner are
actually the Italian really begins.
Uh, that's the, the, the sentence
structure of the English wouldn't allow,
it begins with a mouth that occupies
the primary place in the line.
And Italian is Lubbock the mouth.
Some of the object is,
is, uh, uh, is, is primary
here in English, of course,
to the sinner lifted his
mouth from the savage meal,
wiping it on the hair of the head he had
wasted behind then began that will have
me renew desperate grief,
which even to think of already
rings my heart before I speak of it.
But if my words are to be seed to the
maybe fruit of infamy to the traitor,
I know that she'll see me
speak and weep together.
If we had time.
And I were to ask you whether this lines
remind you of anything in particular.
I'm sure some of you would
immediately jump and tell me.
These are clearly an echo of very good,
in fairness,
five Francesca's language.
The language of love has become now
the language of hatred because from the
point of view of arena,
and that's part of his tragedy.
He can't tell them apart.
He does not know what love
is and what hatred is.
And he can exchange one for the other.
And here we are.
You could even argue that retrospectively,
the language of love, Francesca,
maybe it was also the language of hatred,
but you would be pushing it beyond
the limits of, of bill livability.
I think that Dante is really,
uh, echoing that Francesca, uh,
and the love and the romance with
Paolo in order to explain this hatred.
And that's the,
the blindness of all
Golino and I use the word,
um, uh, deliberately. No, that's,
that isn't all what he lacks is any
perspective on himself and on the world at
island him. So, uh, it
then continues that are,
I ain't know, I know
know who that hard. No,
but what means that has come down here.
But indeed that seems to me
Florentine when I hear the,
the focus is on language language here,
which is a part of one
managing to first of all,
no the other and understand the other,
they may know the
inflections of the dialect,
the Florentine dialect and they may
even think that indeed and Dante's has
allowed to say that if we've got a real
quick idea about the question of uh,
the dialects and they in the,
in the instances that they
can communicate in effect,
there's no possible communication
between the two of them.
If I were to define for you the,
the rhetorical czar that Dante Diprose
here is that of what we call a dramatic
monologue.
Uber Reno goes on speaking and therefore
he expects nor does he get any response
from his interlocutor.
He's a parent.
Interlocutor a dramatic monologue when
he goes home telling us the story of his
life, the way he sees it. You know,
you all know 19th century dramatic
monologues in English literature, right?
If not mean that this is an
occurrence of that genre. I can speak.
I can tell you,
I can go on fictionalizing myself and I
believe that my perspective or the way I
fictionalized myself
will become your reality.
And Dante entices of course,
Uber Reno to do exactly that.
This cause this is exactly,
this is the way in which you are in hell,
where you go on really believing that
whatever you tell that you can go and
telling stories and the save yourself,
deceive yourself, that others are
going to believe what you were saying,
that you will.
The reality that you're going home and
constructing is everybody's accepted
reality.
This is one of the issues clearly that
we were going to confront thou art to
know that I was counting to greener.
This is the archbishop for Jerry.
What an extraordinary line.
And what makes this
extraordinary is first of all,
the occurrence of what do
we call, attributes, titles.
And then the shift in verbal tense.
Who Will,
you know, we'll go on,
uh, attributing time.
I was con count to Galena and this is
there is to say the object of his say
hatred is unalterable is timeless.
And that object of his hatred is
exactly what goes on. Defining him,
right? I time belongs to
me. I know that I belong,
I have a history, there is a history
behind me and there is, and this one here,
the re fied object to
my hatred is unchanging.
I should bishop [inaudible].
So there is that,
the secular and the sacred if you wish,
welds and Gib liens with the idea that uh,
or you know,
had really betrayed the side.
It was a world's becoming a Gerbil in a
given him became my wealth and so on. So,
uh, the, the,
the recapitulation of all the infernal
satanic since we have seen so far.
Uh, and then how bout
how by means of his evil?
I shall tell thee now why I
am such a neighbor to him.
What another extraordinary line
because it's, uh, uh, you know,
the idea of what a neighbor
is, right? Uh, and awkward,
but the neighborhood has become,
uh, this, this is the way,
uh,
neighbors can liberalizing are
cannibalizing one cannibalizing the other.
Um, um, hub. How by means
of his evil devices,
confiding him.
I was taken and then killed.
There is no need to tell pat
what thou canst not have learned.
That is how cool was my death or shall
hear and shall know if he's done me wrong.
And he tells the story that
he was a prisoner in a tower.
We are meant to and understand all the,
the languages of the other Towers Tower,
which isolates him as a tower in Piza.
But the way it's really the tower,
this is, has nothing to do with
this, but I find it irresistible.
If you read the Cantos of Ezra pound,
some of the most extraordinary
poetry of his, uh,
I think comes from when,
when he was declared the traitor.
Um, in, in the aftermath
of the Second World War,
he was put in a cage,
not too far from this tower of Pisa,
which is really one of
the most beautiful part.
It's near the school or
North Malin Piza and a,
and he writes his poetry
about the tower that he sees.
Clearly his own sense of
trying to understand what
treasury, uh, really means.
Um, and, and I,
what I'm really saying is
these are issues that keep
being present in the consciousness of,
of,
of some of the leading
imaginative figures of our time.
So he goes into this little, the, the, um,
the tower of the hunger as it is called,
and we'll shut up.
I had already shown me through it, slit
several moons when I had the bad dream,
which rent for me the veil of the
future. So we are dreams that, uh,
uh,
he has a dream and the mistake he makes
is to think that the dream is going to
be real.
And the dream is this.
This men appear to me as a master and
Lord hunting the wharf and the Welsh, uh,
the,
the world wealth comes from Wolf,
a wolf and Gibbons and the mountains for
which the pieces cannot see Luca with
hounds lien train the Nigga,
he had sent it Valon the,
it's sort of when I woke.
So he has this idea of,
of destruction, the mutual
destruction, so the wolf, et cetera.
When I worked before morning,
I heard my children who were with me
crying in the sleep and asking for bread
that were cool indeed,
if the grievous not now thinking what my
heart for boded and if that will not at
what the style ever weep.
So they were not awake and are
they are now awake. And the,
our approach when a food used to be
brought to us and ditch was afraid because
of his dream and the herd below the
door of the horrible tower nailed up,
which I looked in the faces of my sons
with that as a word, I did not weep.
I saw turned to stone within.
They wept. And Motherwell.
Anselm said, by the way, uh,
to understand how there is a counter,
there's a sort of of of movement between
the horror of this tragedy and the
tenderness,
the pathos of it.
One of the ways in which dentists suggests
this is the use of diminutives for
and said Mucho.
Ah,
this a little kid that he has this
kid that Lucas so farther what?
Trustee at data shed? No tears.
No answer. The whole day. No.
That night after till another
son came fourth in the world,
as soon as the little ray made its
way into the dough for prison and the
discerned in four phases of my own look,
I bet both hands for grief
and they thinking I did it
from a desire to eat rose
up suddenly and said,
father,
it would be far less paid for us if
that eat of us thou the disclosures with
this wretched fresh
and our strip us of it.
I calm myself then not to make them more
unhappy that day in the next we stayed
or silent are hard.
Earth what is done not open.
When we had come to the fourth day,
God to throw himself out stretched
in my feed saying my father,
why does that now? No, I
don't think it's farfetched.
If I were to ask you two over here behind
this question of one of the children
exactly the neck of the prayer of Jesus
on the cross that we heard a few that we
read a few canters back.
So there is a way in which the violence
inflicted on Galina's children seems to
repeat or reenact the great
drama of the Christian sacrifice.
Right.
Cause he are now on are also crucified.
In fact there he died
and the store sees me.
I so the three drop one by one during
the fifth day in the six therefore I gave
myself now blind. That's what it is.
The lack of perspective is he's nothing.
He did a four has no
distance from anything? No.
Can he tell things are
part of distinguish things,
one from the other two grouping over each
and for two days called on them after
they were dead.
Then fasting had more power than griefs
and extraordinarily ambiguous line
because you really do not know what
he's saying according to a role there.
For instance,
we'll go around making a statue of this.
They said the at the Moma and you can
go and see that the story is that of a,
that reno 80 his own church.
Then fasting had more power than grief.
I yielded to the
appetizer the urging of a,
of hunger more than grief.
Or maybe he's saying just something else.
Maybe he saying then fast and
had more power than grief.
I really died of fasting for
hunger rather than for the grief.
We don't know.
And I think that part of the charge it
bode that Dante is starting to conveys to
us is that we are left and this is by
the way a board has a reading book,
has rights, nine uh,
lectures on Dante. What else?
Realizing the importance or number nine
for the antis nine lectures on that.
And one of them is on the story of who
Reno and he says he actually wants us to
live.
He wants to leave us in suspension to
believe that it's possible that he may
have been eating the children,
but maybe it's just the sensibility of
so many critics have been offended by the
suggestion that he actually could go
on a candy, buys him his own children.
And I think that book is is right that
we are not supposed to be able to tell
apart that that ambiguity of that
line is never going to be quite uh,
resolved.
It's going to be forever there,
but the most important element of
this tragic occurrence and the Dante,
before I go on, let me just say a rps or
Dante goes on into an apostrophe gaze.
Piza again with this
language of now he's talks,
he breaks the silence ips,
shame of the peoples of the fair land
where sounds the C and other little touch
of another little echo of the day,
we'll gather,
equate this to say in the moment
where he's dealing with treasury,
which I call the most nihilistic of all
sins because you really declared no and
any bond that you may
have with others he uses.
And that the irony is to me,
glaring the affirmative particle is
if there's any possible affirmation,
there is none.
We're sounds this,
see since they neighbors are
slow to punish the makeup, right?
Django Gona shift and put
a bottle of Nando's mouth,
so the drown every soul in thee.
This is really the kind of language that
all reno himself at youth when before
the consummation of the tragedy,
he really begs the the earth or an
earthquake that the earth may open up and
swallow or all of them here.
Dante's using the exactly the same land.
The idea that's so horrifying is
the spectacle that he has been.
The tragic spectacle has been
witnessing that the whole world here.
That could be an apocalyptic
ending to the work.
But to go back to the
the, the, the key issue,
there may not be time for a
discussion today and I apologize,
but the real tragic event though,
what is the tragic event other than,
okay, what if we go, Leno had the
name of betraying the strongholds.
Thou should not have put his
children to such torment.
So this has been the crucifixion
of innocence, their youthful years,
thou new Thebes besides the new themes
and new three by we have been witnessing
now made them innocent or drone and
regard and the other tool named already in
my song,
this is really the tragic,
Dan has been using other tragic language
indeed that he had been hoping and
theorizing in the Devil Valley
rockets and then they move on.
But what is the really tragic occurrence,
the tragic occurrences in the very
presence of the Christological language in
this camp.
Because the sacrifice of the cross
means one thing and one thing only
that now all violence is finished and
something because we have found the,
the, the scape goat, the voluntary
scape goat who goes around saying, oh,
we're all innocent and
that he is the guilty one.
That's how we are declared. That's how we
are redeemed. That's why we are, we are,
we are made innocent once again,
right?
But this story here,
reenacting and echoing the story of the
cross seems to say the futility since to
announce that utilities,
that sacrifice retrospectively says that
that sacrifice too was just one of the
senseless act of violence that has
happened that have happened in history and
the punctuate human history.
Of course,
this is not the end of the poem,
but it's the most desperate part of the
poem because Dante comes to believe that
the hole that they, the
law of, of, of, of history,
that the law of the is really a tragic
claw and there's something absolute about
it and not,
and not quite escapable.
We shall see how he's
going to move through this.
And I really have to go into
cantillatory for, um, so a little bit,
I would not say too much this time. Can
two, three, four, we're Dante meets Satan.
So the encounter with Satan is first
of all that which gives incredible
coherence to the whole movement of
in federal. It was, as you remember,
the story of inferno began
with the neutral ingroups.
Those who had been sitting,
uh, watching the spectacle of
the disruption of the customers,
the neutral angels at the time of
the, uh, Lucifer's rebellion of, of,
against God.
And now it ends with Lucifer.
So it's really as a kind of angelic,
a cosmic proportion.
The other thing that I have to say is
that if you imagine those of you who are
readers of Milton and paradise lost,
if you,
and you know how what a
brilliant rhetorician, uh,
Satan Lucifer is in, uh,
in, in paradise lost,
you'll be disappointed. In fact, the
Tsl and who writes a comment about this,
as I said,
he says,
I really recommend the first time readers
of the divine comedy to skip Canto 34.
Because it's strange that
Lucifer Satan doesn't speak,
and that was exactly the point
that I'm sorry to say TSL.
It at this time really had probably has
never read that they will get it look
answer then re he's not supposed to
speak because it's one of the angels who
really do not use the human language,
but more importantly
because he represents evil,
defeat defeated from this
point of view. Can Two, three,
four stands in radical
sharp contrast to canter,
33 in Cantata retreat.
We sort,
we have witnessed the sovereignty of evil.
It is as if it were all in golfing
and hovering over all of reality here.
Now we witness exactly the opposite,
how Satan becomes a rarefied dumb object
and actually an instrument for the
pilgrims are sent.
It's going through the body of Lucifer
that the pilgrim can go on and the guide
and Virgil can turn themselves upside
down and finally reemerge to the light.
The rest of the canto good. I think
that we're going to have a few minutes,
but I have to say something
about the rest of the cancer.
The rest of the canned who deals with
the cosmological argument and the
cosmological argument is,
uh,
where does purgatory come from?
And Dante gives an extraordinary events,
a poetic myth and the poetic meter
he events is that when Lucifer Fair
at the time of the grant are
angelic disruption, right?
The first rebellion against,
uh, against the deity,
the earth retreats out of fear
at the approaching of this a,
this, a fallen angel and re-emerges
on the other side of the hemisphere,
the southern hemisphere.
That's the beginning of purgatory.
But you see the connection
from an evil act,
the chances of redemption,
how in effect in Dante's cosmos,
there is nothing which cannot be utilized,
no evil,
which can not be utilized
to the ends of the gut. Uh,
everything they're real defeat of evil
is when that itself can become the
stepping stone over the threshold
of evil itself in order to reach the
purgatorial island.
The last little detail that I will tell
you is I asked you to read the last line
of Canto through you like
this. It's a little detail
that you're like, I hope, uh,
uh, the last line of, uh,
of, of [inaudible], uh, is
a, a queen. Do she, Maria,
let's Lasalle Italian and therefore
we came out to see once again,
the stars. Just a little detail to, uh,
remind you about the extraordinary
love of symmetry in Dante's porn,
right? That each canticle
we'll end with that same word,
Stella, Stella, stars, Stars and stars.
There is to say each canticle
ends with us looking up,
reminding us of where we are and still
longing for the stars so I can come to a
little in a hurry.
I have reached the end of the,
of inferno purgatory now and
then see if there are questions.
Yes.
Can you say a little bit more about
almost like a,
a total perspective through his
construction of the various languages from
seeing different forms of Italian
and trying to get an all encompassing
perspective.
The question is, can I say more?
Good question and the question is,
can I say more about how Dante is
trying to construct our users total
perspectives and you mean
both in the end here?
Yes. Thank you. Because in effect,
I was hoping someone would ask me
this question because I really didn't,
did not tell you how
this the devil got it.
Acquaints is completed here and
why couldn't Dante complete?
They will carry liquids here. When he
wrote a tract, when he wrote a tract,
he wanted to unify,
you know,
he believed that they are the dialects,
14 dialects in Italian.
He had knowledge,
he recognizes 14 directs,
he knew some of them very well
and he wanted to make a eh,
a unified language.
Out of that it kind of artificial
language assault of let's call Italian
experimental,
you know,
something that you could bring
together and what he was lacking.
So much so that they are those scholars
who work on who have been working,
I don't agree with that is that
almost Dante seem to have a kind of,
um, seem to be in agreement
with uh, uh, the so called, um,
um, uh, uh, logicians
those who have, uh, uh,
kind of, uh, the, the, the idea
that language has assault of a,
let's say a Cartesian linguistics
as a kind of, uh, of rational,
a rational structure to it
and that can be really remade.
The point is that when he writes to the
level, got it. [inaudible] this is true.
I don't buy the idea that he's
following the logicians of the, the,
the Middle Ages.
They are Marion's we're really legit ones.
But he did it lacked was a historical
sense and the little detail that he brew
was still the surviving language from
the creation of man to our own time
because, and he had a good theological
argument for that because it would be
inconceivable that the redeemer of the
world would use a language other than the
language that had been employed by,
by Adam.
When he comes to Paradise,
the divine comedy,
he completely changes view in Paradiso.
26 says, I'm going to tell you that.
He says, no, no. He
builds, appeared with, uh,
immediately after Adam fell with
the fall of Adam from the garden.
There was no longer the primal language.
And he goes on elaborating the idea
that God does not use any language,
but the language of this is to say human
beings have the letters and syllables
of God's language. It's not Hebrew.
It's not Latin. It's not Greek.
It's not whatever, uh, slow
Chinese. It's that really the, uh,
we are the syllables. That's
Dante's idea. Policies of 20, 26.
So this was the, that's the, the,
the, the real change. What had,
what does it mean in terms of divide
of the of the inferno is that he had
understood that in order to
write about a unified language,
he had to descend.
Now he could not go on the tower and
from their watch or the the the qualities
aesthetic.
What is the sweet,
what is the Worldcom language and what
is the less welcome, the harsh language.
What are the sounds that he really should
be applying and adopt in two Italian,
but he didn't understand that in
order to have a unified language,
you have to descend into the political
realities of the, of, of this cities.
That's why,
that's the difference between the,
they will get an acquaintance
and the lower in fairness,
a sense of history.
That's really the difference.
And to see this and
the sense of different,
and you can be in a tower as who
greeneries and be blind or you can be in a
tower like Nimrod is and do not even
what you're talking about. You know,
who didn't go on completely reversing,
messing up and confusing the Hebrew
that he, he should have known.
You understand what I'm saying? So that's
really the difference between the two.
Good question was that it allowed me to
focus on a detail that I probably didn't
explain. Very, very cool.
I don't understand how
he could have said that.
Died the fall.
You're on, said why? I don't
understand how Dante could,
could make that statement. Is that what
you're saying? He said, yeah, that's,
uh, I don't think that there are
any traces of Adam's language. Uh,
the,
the question is why it's a sort of a
predicament and I don't know if it,
uh, he, he says he doesn't
quite understand the why,
how Dante could say that Hebrew
died with the fall of man.
Um, uh, that's what he, Adam will
tell him. He, there, he meets,
had them, there is another port because
he's the one who names the world.
Where did the scripture,
the scripture nor in Hebrew
scriptures or you know, uh, the language
of Jesus for instances, Aramaic,
we have to be careful about what
kind of, uh, uh, the kind of, uh,
uh, is that Adam's language or is
that the language? Is the language,
the changes in time, that's all.
That's all he's really saying.
That the new testament that in Aramaic
for instance, which is a dialect.
Yes. So, so this, this goes
back a little bit to the, uh,
to the last lecture, but, um,
looking back over the entirety of,
of inferno,
it seems like Dante expresses
different levels of, of I guess, uh,
sympathy or pity for the
people who are trapped in, in,
in certain circles of hell,
especially for the sellers of discord.
And then later in, in other cases,
like at the end of the 10 to 33,
he's happy to be a churl to someone
who's on being, being tormented.
Oh yes.
What's up?
And, um, I, I just, it's, it's
interesting though, the, um,
the really the different relationship
that, um, that Dante has, uh,
to the different reactions.
He has these punishments,
given that he's essentially
created all of them, that, that,
that in front of is supposed to be
a representation of divine justice,
but it teams like overall. Dot. Hayes,
the judge and executioner here.
Given that the whole,
how sincere leaders does
Dante believe in this?
In this divide.
I think he's in this,
in the divide between himself as as this,
right?
Or who can feel pity for the different,
for the people trapped in
different areas of how vs. Dot.
Hay as as sort of the, the, I mean in some
sense he's the creator of all of this.
It was just sign everyone
to each level of how,
I know this is a broad thing,
but I,
I kind of wanted to see some,
some comment on on that. Dubai,
how sincerely used to submission to him.
The question is,
since Dante is a Dante,
the pilgrim has different responses
to the figures whom he has created.
Sometimes he's tender and sympathetic,
sometimes he just kicks them.
As far as that's the scene.
You are referring to a and
they're all his creations.
How sincere is he in his vision? Um, okay.
This one's is that I would formulate
it a little bit differently,
but you know that that's fine.
Yeah.
We agreed that Dante has is not the
indifferent spectator to all of them and
nothing that what matters to him most
is to show a degree of passionate
involvement with whoever they may be.
He's not going to be sentimentalize
about all of them are for a number of
reasons. It's very sentimental
with his teacher. Uh,
I think he's really very sarcastic with
peer. The Levenia whom you remember,
he marks that language of is the
contrived the I thought he thought.
I thought that's not Dante's language.
That's really because they're living
his own poetry that Dante picking up.
I think that he is very,
he has a sense of pathos.
It may be is also seduced
by Francesca Francesca.
You can put this pastor that she is
trying to seduce him as well as she said,
users or let's powerless and use
said use when it comes further down,
the, the, the relationship is
no longer a relationship of, uh,
of, uh, this tenderness of
forms. Now there is really anger,
anger at what an extraordinary
horror or what human beings can do.
And there's not nothing
Dante calls the fraud.
They seem peculiar to
men that human beings,
they seem peculiar to human
beings because they are,
they have a reason that becomes
part of their premeditation,
part of their machinations of evil.
And I find that that, uh, uh,
uh,
repulsion he has,
I find that I'm very dramatically
speaking, very convincing,
very convincing.
Uh,
it's still part of the judgments that
he's making and it's not an attenuation at
all of that judgment.
The,
the anger with which attacks Piza that,
that idea that he speaks
prophetically there.
Why is this whole place disappearing?
This is, I think that to me is,
you say it's sincere.
I wouldn't be using that language,
but I think that it's dramatically
very powerful. Uh, and that'll roof.
Who would agree that, that probably
the best way of referring to this term,
to the, the th two. Describe
the, this, uh, this situation.
Would you agree?
I find it,
I find it dramatically very apt.
It's a,
because it's a consequence of
the genuine horror. You imagine.
I mean,
you had the earlier,
even diviners with a shape,
a human shape twisted the
head turns around. Uh, uh,
then, uh, uh, the alchemists, uh, uh,
also representing the
kind of twisted forms.
It's this twisting of the human image,
uh,
and this and the reality of what
human beings can do. Uh, an ongoing,
and this says hatred has taken over.
I think that is approaching them too.
There is a way in which I was saying he
echoes w w [inaudible] when Orino says,
you know,
on earth,
why then was there an earthquake
and which would swallow everything.
I mean the, the, the language of
the Itar, the cannibal, so to speak.
And then Dante just says on why
is there some, some kind of great,
uh, uh, uh,
drowning of all this wire on the
islands just moving and just,
and be a barrier so that the
whole town will go under.
I think that there is a way in which
he's almost doing the same thing.
So that's it almost a reenacting the
kind of a sense of nothingness that
[inaudible] had shown to him.
But obviously he does not
agree with two Golino and no,
it's not that there is a
kind of a complete, uh,
identification with them.
And how do we know that this
is not going to be the case?
He's writing reasons.
The poem is what rescues Dante from
yielding to the temptation of absolute
despair and therefore distinguishes him.
It distinguishes own temporary impulse
for nihilism with the nihilism that
distinguishes, characterizes
all the centers and the Volvo,
the treasurers souls.
Okay,
but maybe we should stop here.
We're going to talk about something so
much more serene purgatory next time.